why am i doing this i'm doing this
because society wants me to do this i'm
doing this because my mates
want me to do this it's a [ __ ]
that's not going to happen and i think
it
you showed that little boy inside was
just like
ruined by it sorry it's still quite
emotional
[Music]
what an amazing story what a cruel
amazing twisting career
my next guest has one of the most
fascinating journeys through business
and through life
that i think i've ever heard she spent
her life surrounded by a couple of
people that that i actually consider to
be inspirations of mine one of them is
sir david brailsford who's been the sort
of elite performance coach and cycling
coach for
team sky which went on to win more than
they were ever expected to win
he's the i guess the author of this this
marginal gains thinking which
changed how business and sports teams
function the other person she was
surrounded by throughout her career is
steve peters who
a lot of you will know from the book he
authored the paradox which redefines
from a psychiatrist's point of view how
our mind works and where our behavior
comes from
and the other male figure in her life
that's important for the story you're
about to hear is her brother
david miller who was this incredibly
sort of
highly regarded cyclist british cyclist
who had this cruel twist to his career
where he got involved in the doping
scandal
which really left a stain on british
cycling as we know it
and david miller recounts the story of
him being sat in this
this cafe shop with david brailsford and
being tapped on the shoulder by three
men wearing suits who would then raid
his house and find syringes and that was
one of the key moments in british
sporting history where
i think in many respects things have
never been the same and we always view
our elite performers with an element of
skepticism but this is fran's story
and fran's story is one of tenacity it's
one of success
it's one of jumping off cliffs and
figuring out how to build your skydiver
as you fall
her story is inspiring it's peculiar
she went from starting her own business
to spending i think 12 years that team
sky worked her way up to the very very
top
and when it became team ineos she became
the ceo leading a predominantly male
dominated industry and then out the blue
in the middle of a pandemic
when retail was on its ass she decided
that she was going to change lanes and
become the ceo of bell staff which is a
brand
that has been struggling that's been
making losses and then was then
kicked up the rear end by covid she's
brave
she is unusual she's inspiring
she's tough she describes herself or at
least she
respects the idea of being a difficult
woman something we'll talk about
so without further ado i'm stephen
butler and this is the dire of a ceo
i hope nobody is listening but if you
are then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
fran i i've done a lot of stalking of
your your history your past your
professional
career and uh i was stalking your
twitter feed the other day
and i saw a quote that you'd um you'd
written i guess
in in honor of your brother um david
who is a a world renowned professional
incredibly accomplished cyclist and the
quote said following a boy who loved it
so much he got absorbed into the fabric
of it and has spent a lifetime carrying
the weight
of the cruelty wonder brilliance and
tragedy it would bring him
um is ultimately what got you into the
world of cycling
i was slightly taken aback by some of
those words
cruelty wonder brilliance and tragedy
can you explain why you chose those
words
oh it's a big opening question um
yeah i mean listen my brother was was
unease a very
talented guy he was we were so when we
were about
10 and 12 my parents got divorced my dad
went to live in hong kong and my mom
stayed in the uk i stayed with my mum my
brother went with my dad
and so when we were like kids we'd cross
in the air so he'd come home from hong
kong i'd go out to
he'd come home i'd go out and he had
nothing to do when he was here because
we'd moved so we had no
he had no friends around so my mom
entered him into a cycling club
um and he'd go and he'd do the time
trials he was super good at it
by the literally from like 15 to 19 he'd
gone from never really riding a road
bike to being
like courted by nine of the biggest
teams in the sport
and he got signed very young by a big
french team
and they kind of made all these promises
to my mum about it and he was obviously
you know he was a kid he was
desperate to win the tour de france and
to go and fulfill his dreams and he
totally fell in love with the sport and
he was completely enamored by it and in
the space of five years he'd gone from
this
excited talented you know
brilliant kid to this damaged
incredibly sad deep deeply deeply shamed
young man and it was like
how has a sport done that like how is
this is
it it's a game right like sports a game
it's entertainment
how is that something that's
fundamentally to entertain people
basically ruined him like taking him
down to the core of who he was and it
just
and then he built himself back up and
he's you know he's gone on to do
incredible things but it was just a
the sport has had this unbelievable
impact on my life on my brother's life
on my life on
everything the decisions i've made and
everything else i guess that's why i
chose those words
give me some detail on you talked about
the sport bringing him down to his core
and ruining him what caused that
ah so he went into the sport in 1998
he turned pro which for any of your
listeners who know anything about
cycling was the festina year
so it was the year of the big fastina
scandal where they raided all the hotel
rooms and the guys all kind of protested
and sat down on the road and
only a few of the sort of teams were
able to finish because so many guys got
pulled out of the race
and it was it was the dawning of the epo
era
so it was the era where they discovered
effectively athletes and coaches had
discovered
that you could use epo in the same way
they used build to use altitude training
to perform to
increase physical performance um and it
was just a transformative drug
it was they couldn't detect it they
couldn't test for it and they brought in
some interventions like a hematocrit
test so if your hematocrit went over 450
you'd be pulled out of racing but it was
a it was a health check it wasn't a
doping check
and it was rife basically so when he
this young sort of
dreaming kid went into the sport he he
genuinely thought you could do it clean
you wouldn't ever have to cheat i don't
even think he really knew that much
about doping at that point in his life
and pretty quickly he realized that
actually
most the guys at the very top were
doping that the doping was endemic
that the expectation was you were dope
that that was what you would
need to do if you wanted to be a
professional and you wanted to be any
good
and he resisted it for a really long
time like he he was a time trialer which
is you know race against the clock
basically only racing yourself and so he
really stuck to his time trialling
because he was like i can do that
like with the technology with
aerodynamics with
focus on my training it's a shorter
period of time there's less requirement
to kind of
be as cardiovascularly supreme as the
guys who are trying to win the tour are
um and so he did very very well time
trialling went to his first tour de
france and won yellow
like day one um and but but what was
happening was behind the scenes
this sort of erosion of his belief that
he would be able to do it clean his
his recognition that actually if he if
he really wanted to take it seriously
and try and win the tour
he was going to have to cheat the people
around him that the kind of
network and the framework around him was
people who weren't looking out for him
weren't thinking what's best for him
weren't trying to work out
how to make help him fulfill his
potential they were trying to work out
how to
get him good enough to make enough money
to win you know for them as a business
he was a commodity in their business um
and i'd like i haven't actually ever
told this story but francois mcgrane who
owned coffee's which is like a
company that basically does telephone
loans i don't know what they do now
probably
you know online loans but um he had he
met my mum so when we had all these
teams that were sort of courting david
he met with my mum and he promised her
that he would look after him like
promise looked looked her in the eyes
and said i'll look after him and and yet
he did nothing
like he he built a team that was allowed
to just get on with it he sort of closed
his eyes to it
and actually when the big investigation
into cofferdie started it was francois
mcgrane who effectively
called out my brother he was like i
think moncuti is probably clean but
david miller
i wouldn't put my hand on my heart for
him and it was like you [ __ ] do
you know i mean like
yeah and you and he he's 24 years old
like
what he's the only exposure he's had the
professional support is your team
so if that's what's happened it's your
team and p don't get me wrong david
absolutely has to take responsibility
for his decisions in that
but i for one know that when i was like
19 to 25 i wasn't making the best
decisions i've made in my life
and i had some influential people around
me who had they told me to do things or
if
and it's that insidious thing isn't it
it's a bit like kind of
i was listening to a book the other day
about um
decision making and you know how if you
look at like nazi germany and people say
oh they were just following orders
and there was this big study done
apparently where they put people in a
room and they told them
like there's going to be some there's
going to be a student in there it's a
study i can't really anything with my
gran or someone who did the study
and you're going to press this button
don't worry because
to shock them and the shock's going to
get bigger and bigger and bigger and
it's like and
65 of the people would have pressed the
button that would have effectively
killed the person in the other room
and it's like what and that's the human
condition right so this idea that we
that we would make a better decision or
we'd make a better choice or that we'd
do it differently
people seem to impose that on guys who
decide to cheat in sport or decide to
make these like well
how dare you make that decision it's
like if you were in an environment in a
culture
where that becomes the norm where that
becomes what people do
this idea that you're going to be the
one person who and don't get me wrong i
know there are other people who do that
and
fair play to them that isn't that's
impressive you know that you've been
brought up in a certain way to enable
you to make those decisions
but david was he was fragile he was
impressionable
he was a dreamer he was doing something
he'd always wanted to do
he was passionate and desperate
desperate desperate to
to be a success and i think he just got
taken down the wrong path
you know and you do you feel like you
went through that with him
as a close family
um i'm trying to understand the impact i
had on you being the sister and i know
you
you guys are very close yeah i mean the
impact it had on me was i was
he never he never came to he went to my
mum and told her that he was dating and
and they
they they sort of she just said well
just stop just come home like don't
worry about actually you know sort of at
the very beginning he said
there's a lot of drugs and my mom was
like well just come home go to art
school don't worry about it it's just
cycling
um and yet he stayed and he persisted
and then i think when he
was in 2001 when he eventually made the
decision to kind of
cross the line as it were he he had he
spoke to my mom i think
in that period and she was just like you
you know you have
you have to stop you have to come home
and he was like no i want to do you know
i want i want to be successful i want to
go on this journey
he never had that conversation with me
all i ever saw was the kind of
it was like an erosion of him do you
know me it's like i could tell something
was going on i wasn't an idih i mean
it's like
he's probably he's probably cheating but
he we had all been indoctrinated into it
as well it was like well that's kind of
you turn a blind eye you kind of think
well you know he's
he's doing really well he's you know on
the cover of all the magazines he seems
happy-ish and it was only when he he'd
come home in the off-season
and he'd come come and stay with me and
my mates living in london
and he would he would drink so heavily
that you'd be like
okay this isn't normal you're a
professional athlete and he would the
the depressions he'd sink into and the
self-loathing that he that would come
out and it's like in vino veritas you
know that kind of
this and i'd be like what on earth is
going on here
and then eventually it kind of you i
realized what was happening and i kind
of
felt responsible for never stepping in
and saying something and never being
like you don't need to do this i was
just like
well you know if you're happy and you're
enjoying it and you're doing well
who am i to judge kind of thing um so i
think as a family
it kind of bonded and pulled us apart
like we kind of
we all turn a blind eye to it i think
we've all got our demons to deal with
from that perspective um my dad
i think was had a very different view of
it all my brother and my dad sort of
you know have have an ongoing difficult
relationship my mum and my brother are
very close i'm very close to my dad and
my mum but you know so
as a family we've kind of it it's
definitely created divisions
because everyone had a different view of
it and then in terms of the impact on me
i went into cycling i ran my own cycling
agency i was working in the cycling
industry i totally rode the coattails of
my brother's success
and i was like [ __ ] okay now it's all
gonna come crashing like he got arrested
and
put in prison and you know i was like oh
god this is not ideal
and i literally remember speaking to him
afterwards and he'd just come out of
you know 48 hours in custody and he was
like
and i remember it being like a week and
a half before the tour and he said to me
don't worry france um they're still
gonna let me ride the tour
you know you're like oh it still makes
me want to cry because it's like david
they're not gonna let you ride at all
that's not gonna happen and i think it
you show that little boy
inside it was just like ruined by it
sorry it's still
quite emotional but yeah so it just it
just impacted everything it impacted all
my decisions because at that point i was
then like
[ __ ] now i've got to go into the office
the next day and i've got to stand in
the velodrome events and
i'm david i'm not david miller's sister
the kind of glory
front cover of the magazine i'm that i'm
the sister of this
shamed cheating lying horrible human
being who
no one likes anymore and who has
disgraced british cycling and is is a
you know he he's like a complete social
pariah
and i'm like oh [ __ ] okay now i've still
got to go and do my job and did you feel
that
you felt your judgment and yeah
massively people would re and it was in
the days of forums you know like
my forums were a really big deal and i'd
be like okay i'm just going to have a
little bit of a look on a forum and see
what people are saying
and i'd see people i work with
commenting you know people who
were at the velodrome who were like
doing the timing at my events or
and they all you know literally like
people wishing him dead
but you know it was just like it wasn't
cool and
yeah i really felt i felt it for him i
didn't i wasn't embarrassed because i
was like
you know it is what it is he's made a
set of decisions he's paying the price
for it
um but it was at that point sort of
about six months after that i was like
okay i
probably can't represent him anymore
because if i have to have another
conversation with a journalist an
ignorant journalist about
this kind of binary right or wrong
conversation
where you're like this is not how life
works i'm gonna end up punching someone
in the face so i should probably stop
doing that
speaking of punching people in the face
no um i had it just that felt like a
good
turn towards one of the things that i
saw you share online which was this
article about being a difficult woman
and the importance of
um dispelling this sort of like niceness
aura that women typically um
are associated with in business that i
think the article was suggesting holds
them back
how important has that been especially
you know
when you were dealing in an industry
which is pretty much full of men and you
got to the very very top as the ceo of
ineos how important was it to
be willing to punch people in the face
being a little bit difficult at times
as is such an interesting question
because that whole being a difficult
woman
i think is the older i've gotten the
more i've kind of explored feminism and
explored kind of
the sort of female condition the human
condition it's like
women are judged very differently for
for behaviors that in men would be seen
as completely normal so
you know there's a sort of famous kind
of meme that's the sort of you know
men are assertive women are chippy you
know men are confident women are
arrogant you know it's like
the same behavior gets viewed very
differently to a very different lens
i've never filtered myself it's not been
anyone who's ever met me knows that i
don't really come with a filter
and i think it's really really important
that young women
recognize that they don't have to apply
a filter you don't have to be the quiet
one in the room you don't have to
i remember reading um cheryl sandberg's
book about lean in and it was like
um you know when young women will come
into a meet room and they won't sit at
the table like
they physically won't sit at the table
they'll sit back at the sides and i was
like [ __ ] off who does that
and then i'd go to meetings and i'd be
like i've noticed that like the
19 20 21 year old younger women in the
room they'd wait for the guys to sit
down
they'd be like what the [ __ ] are people
why are people doing that
and it you just until you realize it's
happening you don't realize it's
happening
and so yeah i've always felt quite
strongly that you just need to be
yourself
be confident be willing to get get told
you're a [ __ ] get told you're and don't
get wrong when i was younger i was
actually a bit of a [ __ ] i probably
i probably didn't um measure that
behavior i was a bit like well it's just
who i am and everyone needs to suck that
up and actually
you still have to be polite and have
manners and you still have to recognize
that being aggressive
is actually just sometimes being
aggressive it's not being assertive
and that balance i think i've learned as
i've got older but i think it's
yeah i think women are judged totally
differently for behaviors that men would
be absolutely
it would it would almost be uh sort of
respected in a man for certain behaviors
and in women it's it's reviled there'll
be there'll be young women listening to
this
and they'll be thinking you know i'd
love to be like that fran and i'd love
to be a bit more you know assertive and
etc etc but i just you know it's just
not who i am and so
kind of the question that popped into my
mind was where did that you know some
might see it as confidence but it's like
a confidence in being your true self
right
where did that do you know where that
came from in you was it
you know is there experience is it
something happening in the household is
that your mother was
taught you that behavior your father
yeah i think it's probably half nature
half nurture like i think i
i you know my mum tells a story about
when i was little and i said
you know i'd just literally go off and
speak to people like she she'd be sat at
you know the bar you know on a holiday
and she'd want to know what's going on
with a couple over there she'd be like
francis go and ask them what they're
doing you might be like okay
and off i'd go and chat to them so i
think i've always been very innately
confident and that doesn't
that's never gone away um but equally i
think
i've been very lucky i've been very
blessed i've worked with people
and in and around people where i've been
allowed to be myself i've been allowed
to kind of grow up and make mistakes and
fail and be a bit of an idiot and get
told you're being a bit of an idiot and
not
not have that be a judgement upon me and
limit me
um and i think it's really interesting
that kind of you know being assertive or
being
being your true self has become a bigger
and bigger thing that people talk about
and actually being your true self
doesn't mean you have to be assertive
and confident it means you have to be
your true self
and for a lot of people that is a bit
more insecure or a bit more
and that's fine but you can bring that
to the table you can be an emotional
person you can be
lack a bit of self-esteem and just be
honest about that so for me i think it's
just
partially how i was brought up but more
the people i have been surrounded by on
the journey of my life and career
i've been incredibly blessed that they
have allowed me to
make a lot of mistakes and correct and
course correct me
as i've gone on that that point about
being assertive and being direct and
being
open and honest you know what um i was
actually chatting yesterday about one of
the
how i've changed over the last 10 years
from like the kid at 18 to the kid at
28.
and the the key thing i said to my team
is like the big change that i've seen on
myself is i'm
way more direct yeah and i'm not sure
why i'm doing that i'm like i don't know
whether
it's because i've got so many things to
do that i'm trying to save time at all
times
um i'm way more honest with my feedback
and there's this sort of fine line
between being an [ __ ]
and being honest and direct and trying
to be time efficient and like realizing
that
sometimes your feedback or the way you
say things might hurt people's
feelings but that's secondary to what
we're doing here um
how have you toed that line i imagine
from what you've said it's more
difficult as a woman
to to because people will you know
they'll they'll determine the same
behavior to be a really negative thing
but how do you toe the line between
being like direct and firm which is so
important in my opinion
when you're dealing with teams and
especially if you're dealing with teams
of uh
you know high testosterone testosterone
men how do you toe that line and
and also i guess the more important
question for me is do you agree
that it's an important trait to have
okay so have you read a book called
radical camber
it's up there on my bookshelf somewhere
but i've not read it yet okay so
yes i do think being honest is important
i think being a [ __ ] to people is
not acceptable
and so i think i i think honestly can
get veiled
sorry being a [ __ ] can get failed by
i'm being honest right
like well i'm just being honest and it's
feedback and you should take it it's
like
one of the sort of best lessons i've
ever been taught
and one of the most influential people
in my life by a mile is steve peters
um he's a forensic psychiatrist yeah and
he
always says like you have to be
compassionate like
even if you're telling someone they're
losing their job or you know if you're
having to give someone really honest be
compassionate be be sensitive to the
fact that
you're going to get a better response
from someone if you're just nice to them
you know
you can say some really really shitty
things to people and
it get a horrible response or you can
say shitty things
but get a really positive response back
because you do it in a different way so
i think
it's really crucial to be honest it's
really crucial to be authentic
but that doesn't mean you get a license
to be a [ __ ]
and have you is there a place
for aggression and anger and
being annoyed in business in your view
no not not ever uh well you can
you can feel those things but i don't
think you can inflict those things on
other people no
i don't think that's acceptable it's um
it's remarkable how many of the world's
most sort of admired leaders when you
read their biographies and stuff you
find out how
much of a [ __ ] they are like steve
jobs was a good example where
i was told you know from a friend that
they basically had to put him in his own
building and warn people that worked in
that building that you know
the way steve was and elon musk in his
biography is
is very very similar but uh the reason i
asked you about radical canada is
when i read it it made a lot of sense to
me about
about people like that so that she
basically describes this quadrant where
effectively you've got
how much you care about people and how
sort of willing and honest
you're able to be and so if you're very
very honest but you don't care about
them at all
then you you're basically an arrogant
[ __ ] and if you really really care
about them but you're really really
honest
then you're radically candid but if you
really really care about them and you're
not honest
then you're kind of it's almost like a
malignant empathy do you know me it's
like i'm going to be really nice to you
but because i'm not going to be honest
with you you're not going to develop
and so that for the first time and she
said in a business
it's better it's way better as much as
it's counterintuitive
to be the arrogant [ __ ] because
actually the feedback is what's
important
so if people are getting the feedback
and they're being told the truth they
are like
some people might be able to handle it
but the people who can handle it will
develop and get better
it's worse to be empathetic and not be
honest than it is to be an arrogant
[ __ ]
and i was like oh that's why there's so
many arrogant [ __ ] in the world
because actually it does work like on
the and genius
you know it forgives a lot right when
people are geniuses they can behave
very differently and they get away with
it because they're geniuses and
there is merit in that and i think if
people are very very very honest with
you and give you brutal feedback
as long as you're like able to take it
on board you'll get better
but if someone's lying to you and saying
you're doing a great job stephen don't
worry about it it's absolutely fine
because they don't want to hurt your
feelings you're never going to develop
that's true you you switched from
working
over to bell staff um quite relatively
recently
um and i was reading i think i was
listening to one of the the podcasts
you've done and you talked about how
you'd worked in cycling pretty much your
whole life it was your
pretty much your everything in terms of
your professional experience um i've
also recently quit my job
and uh how does it feel uh everything
you feel everything right you feel
you know it's bittersweet you feel
excited on one hand you're unsure about
the future but i trust myself enough to
know that i'll figure it out because i
always have
um but yeah all feelings um i guess my
question for you is
and the bit that i found particularly
interesting is people
will do a thing for ten years for five
years whatever and then they'll tell
themselves that they are that thing
they'll like give themselves the label i
work in cycling i'm a cycling person
yeah it seems to be incredibly difficult
especially if they've been in that
industry for a long time to then
take on a different label you're now
working in fashion and it comes with a
whole new set of challenges completely
outside of your
comfort zone to some extent in some ways
how did you make that switch
how did it feel tell tell me all about
it um
it's again i'm going to reference steve
peters but i remember because i was
so wedded to my job in cycling like i
lived and breathed it i
loved it i cared deeply about the people
it like had this
it was so wrapped up in my identity but
i hadn't
necessarily got a huge amount of
satisfaction out of the job over the
last two or three years
for a whole host of reasons nothing to
do with the team just personal
development wise
and every time i spoke to steve you'd be
like well then why don't you just leave
i'd be like
because i don't know who i am if i leave
the cycling team do i mean and
that was a much longer conversation than
that but what effectively i was saying
was i don't know who i am if i'm not
that
and he he said over and over again
you will be whoever you go on to be
that's not going to change you are still
there
you're letting this thing influence all
these views about yourself you're
letting it influence what you
your value your worth your you know your
sort of substance your contribution to
life like
you're letting it's a job it's like it's
a job and i was like you don't get it
you don't understand it's more important
than that and you know what when i got
asked to go and do bell stuff and i left
and it broke my heart like i
cried my eyes out and i started a bell
staff and i
i sat feel awful saying this but within
48 hours i was like
oh my god i love it here and i love the
people here and this is brilliant i'm so
excited and actually
it is just the job that was just the job
and yes i miss it and yes it was
incredible and yes i
loved the people and i still love the
people but it's just the job
it's not my family it's not who i am
it's not my identity it's just
a part of my life and i'll be eternally
grateful for having done it but now i've
got a new challenge and i was like
i'm really pleased i did it when i did
because everyone i think
had been saying to me for a long time
you know once you leave you'll be like
oh i should have done this five years
ago
and i don't feel like that at all i feel
you know i did that for the right amount
of time
i loved it i've banked it moving on to
something else
and it's that point there about thinking
that that job was your identity that i
think really like holds people down
yeah um because you're right jobs are
they're fat friends they're community
they are purpose yeah
as you say they're your identity um
and that's dangerous like that's
dangerous you know because actually
they're not they're not they're not your
identity and no matter how much you love
it
no matter how passionate you are about
it if you
it then this would be the lesson i would
sort of give to myself the sort of
it doesn't matter it's a job you're
being paid to do it it's a job and
and i would have railed against that
even a year ago
like no it isn't it's more important
than that and you know as soon as you
as soon as i left i was like yesterday
and my brother always you say to me your
team aren't your family
your team aren't your family and i never
really understood what you meant because
i thought well they are my family
like you know what i mean i love them
they are my family and they leave you
like oh no what he means is your family
are there forever your family are
wedded and you can't un-pick your family
they they're something that's whereas
when you leave a job
you take away the memories you take away
the happy times to take away the good
stuff
but you're the fabric of who you are
doesn't change
and that's what i try and do i just
finished writing my book on there's a
chapter on this idea of labels and me
trying to resist these labels
to make sure that i continue on my
journey of challenge and keep myself you
know stimulated and i don't get to
you know a certain age and feel like i'm
having a midlife crisis because i don't
know who i am and i can't leave and i
don't have any skills
um and to really sort of realize that
the label i have
is me it's like steven i'm a guy with a
bunch of skills and experiences
and i can apply these skills and
experiences to a bunch of different
challenges
i'm not social media ceo you know what i
mean yeah and that i find really
liberating
so i quit i started djing we're doing
this pokemon this theatrical play i'm
just trying to do all of the things that
i think i shouldn't be able to do right
but speak to me about the challenge so
you you decide to take this job at bell
staff and it is a big challenge
it's it's widely reported that bell's
staff has been it's
had you know struggled across the years
it was recent it was acquired and i
think 2017.
it was making losses then and the losses
of i think narrowed over the last couple
of years to some extent but it's a big
challenge right
a big challenge it would have been much
easier to take a different job
so first and foremost i didn't take it i
was i literally
had a conversation with my chairman
ineos um
about you know maybe maybe over the next
couple of years i want to think about
moving on and doing something different
and
when we when dave b comes back from the
tour this was in september so when he
comes back from the tour at the end of
the season i think
i'd like to sit down and have a chat
with my chairman and my boss dave
about my future that was the sum total
of my conversation
and literally a week later i got a call
saying jim would like you to be the ceo
of old stuff
and you know with the best one in the
world when jim ratcliffe asks you to do
something you don't kind of go
let me have a think about that and i
just thought okay well what an
opportunity and and i went for it
but i didn't i wasn't looking to change
i wasn't i hadn't like planned to move
on
so that was in some ways whilst it was
quite traumatic sort of three or four
weeks of
because i literally i got phoned like on
the 16th of september and i was enrolled
on the first of october
wow so it was like yeah like two weeks
of just why did you want to have the
conversation though when they've
got back because i wanted to so i wanted
to i'd sort of been thinking like i said
about the conversation with steve about
kind of
i'm not sure if i'm happy doing this job
anymore and i'm not sure if i'm
fulfilled
i've kind of reached the point sort of
middle of last year
where i was thinking you know what i do
need to start thinking about my future
in my life and my career and i don't
know whether that's always going to be
in cycling and i don't know whether the
ceo of the cycling team
is 100 y1 so i wanted to speak to my
chairman first to kind of sound him out
and then when dave gets back from racing
i don't want to interfere with the
racing
have a conversation about my future so i
just literally put it on the rate the
radar of the german
i'd probably be a little bit out of
frustration for myself as well but like
i want to
feel like i'm moving this on because
otherwise i'm going to sit and not do
anything with it do you know what i mean
i'm going to
did you feel stagnant yeah in the role
is that the main the crux of what you're
getting at what was the
person if i can relate uh i think
i felt so i had done
what was effectively 20 years in pro
cycling it would like you say it was all
i knew it's all i'd done
i know everybody in it pretty much you
know i've been in and around it my whole
life i'm david miller's little sister
it's like you know part of my dna we got
we and i loved being part of team sky
like we did that for 10 years and it was
i sort of always say cup in the middle
like blue blue and i absolutely loved it
and then when skye said they were out at
the end of 2018 i was like right i'm
done i'm out of here i'm not going to do
this anymore so i went straight to baby
i was like
it's been amazing i've loved it but i'm
gonna once the team
stops being sky i'm gonna go and he was
like okay cool
i don't think he believed me he was like
okay cool and then
we he said to me look would you help at
least find a new sponsor let's see if we
can find a new sponsor he's a bugger
like that so i was like okay i'll try
and help you find a new sponsor and then
i'll move on
and then you know february comes 2019
you know he's he meets jim
jim decides that he wants to acquire the
team you know
he jim's arguably one of the most
successful businessman in the world
we went and met with him and talked
about you know the design of the kit and
everything else and i was like i'm gonna
get sucked into it
um and then and then one of the other
senior managers in the team decided to
leave and go and work for another team
and debbie was like would you stay you
can be ceo
which was what i really wanted to be
it's a massive opportunity and i was
like okay i'll stay
and i think that was the point of the
decision there that i was like
you know this is a big career decision
to me that i'm staying again i told on
my mates i was going to leave i was like
you know this is it this time this time
i'm going they're like
okay um and so i
stayed at ineos and then we worked on
the one five nine project
so elliott kip togues up to our marathon
and dave obviously was the project lead
on it all he was the ceo
my boss um but he very sadly got
prostate cancer
in that period so he was off doing the
tour de france then he had to go and
have surgery
and so i took on like a deputy ceo role
kind of delivering the sort of vision
that he'd come up with and he structured
all the performance team but then i was
doing the delivery of the event
everything from kind of working with the
london marathon team to
supporting the performance guys to doing
all the engagement piece and everything
else
and i loved it as i felt like i was
working 18 hours a day for like
what was about five six weeks in the
build up to the first of all the test
event and then through into the actual
event
and i just loved it totally different
totally new challenge
new people different approach fresh it
was
i was like i was on literally cloud nine
i couldn't have loved it more
and i was working so hard like i was
literally crippled by it
but i loved it and i came out the other
side of it not so much just because
we've done it obviously i mean that was
incredible
but it just really made me realize that
i was just going through the motions in
in the cycling job i was just i was
ticking over i was really comfortable
i was good at it i loved it i was happy
i liked the people but i wasn't growing
i wasn't developing i wasn't learning
new stuff and i wasn't kind of and i'd
been going at a million miles an hour
you know sort of in the team like on all
these stuff where i was
helping other people develop and helping
other people achieve their potential and
helping other people kind of
you know rescue their reputations or
enhance their
and i was a bit like what do i want to
be doing like why am i
i'm not none of this has been about me
and even actually cycling is a little
bit about david you know what i mean i
was on kind of this journey to sort of
save young british talent from going
through what david went through and it's
like actually what do i want to do
maybe i want to do something different
and that just
planted a seed really and i think i
probably went this way to the gym and
you know if i'm honest i went because i
thought i want to go and do something
different i'm ready i'm ready to move on
i'm ready to do something that's not
this anymore
and it was all it was almost like a kind
of involuntary i think everything else
about me was like just stay because it's
comfortable and it's easy and
you get good money and it's you know
nothing's gonna nothing but that's gonna
happen
but my like soul was like you've got to
you've got to go and do something else
now
and it was literally like in the space
of two weeks it was like boom i'm i'm
out of here
so it was that see it almost identical
to me in the sense of something niggling
at you
and then for me there was like a trigger
moment where i was like
i was like sent an email
yeah yeah yeah and then you just send it
and then but that idea of being able to
throw yourself into uncertainty it's
like throwing yourself
off a cliff when you were like cushy in
the house on the side of the cliff and
you was like oh my god i'm gonna jump
and you're throwing yourself off into
the unknown in in the hope
that so you'll build your glider as you
fall and then land somewhere better
and a lot of people can't do that like
most people can't do that
how do you how did you feel though about
because because i found it really
traumatic
like i kind of i felt like oh first of
all i felt quite out
it was like i'm out of control of this
now i literally said goodbye to my team
who i'd worked with for 10 years and
got on a train woke up the next day and
went into bell stuff and like hi i'm
your new ceo
and i and that the trauma of kind of all
of it
it felt i had to move out my house i had
to go and do
say goodbye to people do have a
different email had the same email my
whole life
like all that kind of stuff it just
doesn't shouldn't be that important but
felt really significant
how did you feel did you find it
traumatic or not so i i'd already i'd
quit
business when i that i was my baby as
well when i was i started business 18
quit that one when i was 21
so i'd been through it once before so
when i earlier when i said the key thing
for me was trusting myself i've done
this before
i know the feelings i know that i don't
know what my future holds
but when i did that when i was 21 it led
to this even bigger business that was
200 times bigger and 200 times more
successful so that was
that's been this guiding thing in my
life like i dropped out of university
after one lecture and it worked out
so when you have those case studies you
think you know what i have no idea what
the future holds
but i'll back myself to figure it out
now and um
that's because i've done it like three
times before so
i imagine the next time in the future if
ever that you decide to
jump ship and build stuff or whatever
you'll have that case study
or that evidence in yourself that you've
been yeah and that that i think will
calm
you a little bit the first time i quit i
was all kinds of emotions and worrying
and not sure what i was now and all
those things but
slightly easier the third time i'm a bit
of a prolific quitter i think it's a
really underrated skill
yeah people talk a lot about starting as
if it's the be all and then and end all
of success but quitting is the thing you
do right before right you start
something new so yeah yeah
i've been a heel fan for a long time as
you obviously know by now but in the
last six months i've got a
real opportunity to get to know the
people to get to know the ceo of huel
which is james to get to know the
founder which is julian
the teams that agonize over the
ingredients that go into these amazing
recipes
and i can honestly say with my hand on
my heart my appreciation
and admiration for huel and its people
has multiplied by a factor of 10
because and this is these singularities
not only are they nice people
but because i've seen firsthand how much
they are non-negotiable
about the values of fuel they will not
compromise they will not compromise on
the the goodness of the ingredients that
goes into the products the amount of
proteins and minerals and these things
regardless if they can't get to where
they want to get to with the products
they will cancel the product i've tasted
products and they said we've not managed
to make it this
we've not delivered on our promise of
veganism we've not added enough fiber
so we're canceling it and that sort of
non-negotiable set of values
has made me realize that they have my
back when i choose you
i was reading about this winning
behaviors role you took on which is a
very curious title
yes it is what was your remit as the
head of winning behaviors that team
ineos
so it was it was when it was team sky
okay um same time um
so basically 2010 we first started
racing we started the team and he was
begun the journey of starting the team
in 2008 off the back of the beijing
games
started racing in 2010 we were [ __ ] like
embarrassingly [ __ ]
and we've been like smoking mirrors and
like you know we're kind of we had the
big bus and we had all the money and we
were sponsored by sky and it's like oh
we're going to be amazing and we were
rubbish
so we totally reset everything and dave
beats be fair to him he's like a
master of okay we're going this way it's
not working we're going somewhere else
but he's
he's incredible assay and so he totally
shifted the way that we're going to run
the team
we took a totally different approach we
started to be very successful in 2011
we'd obviously set the objective when we
announced the team that we were going to
try and win the tour de france with a
clean british rider
in five years and that was in start
2010.
bradley won the tour in 2012. so within
the space of two years
three years effectively we've done it
the following year
chris froome won it and we had gone from
being this team that was like
on a mission like heads down arses up
and we were going like there was nothing
was going to stop us we were full-on
and so when people sign up to that you
know people are signing contracts in
2010 with a team that doesn't exist
that has never raced on the road before
that comes from a track background
that's full of brits who aren't
historically
that famous for road cycling they were
they were signing a kind of you know
they were they were adventurers right
they were like these bold ambitious this
is a bit batshit crazy but we'll do it
when people were signing contracts at
the end of 2013 they were signing with a
team that had won the tour de france
twice that was
arguably the most dominant team in the
sport that had gone on you know sort of
achieved this inc
these incredible feats and they had a
different expectation of what they were
joining to what we were
and we suddenly realized that actually
if we were serious about
continuing and continuing to be
successful codifying what
got us where we were was going to be
crucial and we'd also seen
for those of you listeners who are
cycling fans we'd had the bradley
wiggins and chris rooms kind of
divide so brad had obviously come first
in 2012 but freemiu had come second
bradley didn't even bradley never rode
the tour again so bradley didn't ride in
2013
from he did and he went on to win and he
started to see this divide in a team
where it's like well i'm team bradley or
i'm team freeman is like
no check your paycheck your team sky and
that
that kind of actually who are we what do
we stand for what do we expect from
people
what do we need to be able to do to be
the best in the world of this
needed codifying and it needed it needed
a way of a sort of
charter almost to tell people this is
how you're going to have to do this and
really it was about eradicating losing
behavior it was about saying to people
bitching backstabbing saying you're team
through me or your team brad or you know
criticizing people behind their back or
whatever
that's not acceptable but you being head
of losing behavior would have been [ __ ]
so we called it
[Music]
so it was all about creating a set of
behaviors for the organization
that enabled us to say to people this is
what it means to put this jersey on
this is what it means to be a part of
this team it's not just about
you know the glory and the winning this
is hard graft this is
you know it it was arguably the hardest
thing i've ever done you know working in
that environment it's
it is unrelenting it is i mean it's
brilliant and it's
amazing and incredibly good fun but it's
hard hard work
and you've got to go all in you know
this isn't this isn't for the
faint-hearted
and so the whole winning behavior thing
was about creating an environment where
we could give people
the parameters that we expected them to
live by but also ensure that they felt
supported
safe able to deliver their very best in
an environment that is actually very
high pressure
so that was my job effectively helping
dave create the behaviors in the first
instance with the whole team
and then helping keep them alive within
the business what were some of those you
mentioned a couple of them there about
not being a backstabber and
understanding the importance of hard
work what were some of the other
um let's just focus on losing behaviors
some of the some of the traits or
some of the threats to success that
you'd see in the team
i'm thinking this from an organizational
standpoint as like yeah that's worked in
business
so we separated them into five different
areas we had self
team um communication continuous
improvement
and uh what was the other one
oh it's gone anyway so quickly how
quickly you move on right
um but the the so they were t itself was
all about identifying your own
managing your own emotions being in
control of your own emotions so a losing
behavior of that would be
losing your [ __ ] you know being
aggressive and arrogant with people
not being able to recognize when you
were too emotional to be in a high
performance environment we have this
the whole chimp model you know steve's
philosophy around that is there's
nothing wrong with being emotional
there's nothing wrong with having a
chimp
but you have to know when to get out the
room if that's what's going on don't
bring your emotion into an environment
where you're expecting people to perform
at their very best
so that kind of management itself
absolutely critical
and then team was all about the impact
that you have as a
team member you know i think people kind
of think teams this kind of
static thing that you create a great
team and that's it it's like as you all
know having won six
very successful businesses teams like
these organic ever-changing you know you
could bring one person in and have a
massive impact on the team
you take one person out it can ruin a
team do you know me so they're sort of
the dynamics of a team and your role
within that are crucial so
you know not wearing a team kit you know
wearing a slightly different trainer
you know um criticizing the team not
buying into the sort of collective
opinion not sort of
dave b has this really big thing about
he'll listen he'll seek counsel from
everyone he'll listen to everyone's
opinion he wants to get to collective
opinion he wants to get to a collective
view of what the right direction is but
ultimately if we can't get there he'll
make the call
and then you've all got to be on the bus
non-negotiable if you sit in a meeting
room
and you agree with something and you say
yeah okay whilst i don't agree with it i
buy in
you know what i mean i've given you my
point of view you've said it's not
the way we're going to go but i buy in
and then you walk out the room and
you're like
i don't know if i can buy that that is
that is the one of the worst losing
behaviors you can have
because it's insidious and it it goes
around you know a whole organization can
be destroyed by a is like a virus
so things like that fascinating
i am you don't do a lot of public
speaking right you used to haven't done
it for a while now actually yeah
but like white collar crime i think
sometimes but yeah so i
i sort of i used to love doing it like i
really did used to love doing it but
i've also
i feel like the bit that i talked about
which is some of the stuff i've just
said
i feel like that's a bit of my past now
and i want to build a new build a new
path for myself before i figure out
telling people about it if that makes
sense yeah
so i don't want to take talks on social
media anymore if i can help it to be
honest for the same reasons yeah
i mean you talked a lot about dave as
well so david brailsford um
and very fondly i think a lot of your
tweets from my stalking were
were centered around him and things that
he was doing yeah what are some of the
the key qualities of of him that have
made him so successful
and his mindset or you know oh
big question i mean him and steve peters
are the two most influential men in my
life without a shadow of a doubt
um you know they they are symbiotic
because they are
i think if dave hadn't had steve he
maybe wouldn't be who he is and i think
his steve hadn't met dave he
maybe would be a slightly different
version of himself so they they
complement each other brilliantly dave
is
is a brilliant man manager he's he's
incredibly visionary
he's very brave you know you said the
thing about jumping off a cliff and
hoping you get your gliders
you put dave's like the king of that
dave's like we're gonna go we're gonna
go and achieve that and everyone's like
[ __ ] off and he's like come on let's go
and he and people are like okay because
he's so he's so bold with it he's so
confident with it that he and he's an
incredible leader that people would
literally i mean i would have followed
that man off the edge of a cliff
and i think that he has that quality in
him you know he's unrelenting
you know anyone who's working he's
difficult you know like all
geniuses are he's a he's a tricky guy
he's why
um how maybe is a better question
in all kinds of ways you know he's very
i think i've spoken about it on other
interviews i've done he can be very um
he can be
very particular he's very
detail-oriented he's
he wants to know all the facts before he
makes a decision he'll
he'll go out he'll like go after
something for age ages and you're like
oh my god
makes a decision i'll get on with it and
then he'll make a decision that's
totally off to the other side and you're
like oh
so doesn't make sense yeah or it's or
it's
brilliantly genius because you think oh
all that work that you were doing and
the decision i would have made and just
got on with it and made the decision
would have taken us that way and that
would have been the wrong way and it's
and it's that kind of you
all the way through my career with him
he would do that and i'd be like
it's just he's just clever like that you
know he's he's
ferocious appetite for learning he
unrelenting work ethic
you know expects incredible sets
incredibly high standards and expects
people to meet them
and all people can right no absolutely
and he'd and you know
we openly say that it's not all people
can there's nothing wrong with not being
able to meet them
you've got to be compassionately
ruthless you know that's what he always
says
which is basically if you're not if
you're not you set a standard and if
people can't meet them
then they're not in the right
organization and it's best there it's a
bit like the arrogant [ __ ] it's
better to be honest with them
and say you know what this isn't for you
than to kind of allow them to keep
failing
i think that can be very cruel to people
you know if they're in an environment
they're constantly trying to be better
but they just
can't do it that's yeah you talked a lot
about
when we were talking about winning
behaviors about this important about
high work ethic and you've expressed
that dave has a
relentless work ethic as well um you
you've probably observed how this
narrative around hard work has become
somewhat toxic over the last
couple of years and now i i you know
almost feel bad sometimes when i'm
what i'm saying that i don't know how i
would have been successful in what i've
done
if i hadn't have worked hard in fact i
don't really know anybody that's
really successful in their discipline or
their sport or whatever that doesn't
work
hard so i know we're not trying to give
anyone
depression and anxiety by saying that
you know
they have to be a hustle porn star they
won't be happy but
i still can't get to the point where i
will tell anybody that hard work doesn't
matter yeah
it really really matters to me and it's
i can't imagine
and you know what i was in the gym last
night and i was thinking sometimes words
really mess people up right so this i
like when people say work they think of
me on like a in a factory like
or in like like i don't know in a mine
hammering some rock all day
but i was thinking because i enjoy my
work so much imagine if i just changed
the words of my hard pleasure
yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah can
you have too much
of hard pleasure
um it's interesting as you were asking
me the question i think that
my respect because i actually i
similarly read something that you'd
written about you
you feel a bit of you feel a bit bad
that you sort of
hear heroes the kind of i'm working yeah
they're kind of 18 hours a day and i'm
going out
about it yeah bragged about it yeah and
and i sort of think
i get it i get why people feel like that
and i think there's a difference between
being
exceptionally busy and working all the
hours god gives and
thrashing yourself and all those sorts
of things and working really hard with
purpose
they're very different you know what i
mean and when you're working really hard
with purpose
and you're passionate about what you're
doing and you love the people you're
working with
and you're enjoying the the sort of
striving for the achievement
there's no shame in that that that's for
me that's absolutely part of
motivated ambitious people that's what
you want them to feel
and people used to know what's something
in the work life balance there isn't a
work-life balance my work is my life
and i make no i make no sort of excuse
for that
i love it i'm passionate about it i
enjoy it i have
it's hard pleasure you know it's
brilliant and i like the challenge of it
and like you know
i chose not to have kids i don't have a
partner it's it's
the passion point of my life is my work
and that's right but that doesn't mean i
need to be
you know not going out and seeing my
mates it doesn't mean i need to be up
until midnight
tapping out emails you know i mean i can
still i take days off
i you know i live a normal life but i
work really really hard
i've i've also struggled in the
relationship department yeah and
surprisingly
never you know been that good at
relationships i've never been able to
hold a relationship down
um i can't really see how it happens
necessarily
i hear you talk to me about that part of
i was gonna call it sacrifice but when
it's somewhat intentional
yeah when you're aware of it it's hard
to call it sacrifice just doesn't
motivate me i know that sounds awful
i'm not motivated to have somebody in my
life i'm not motivated to be like
i want a partner i want that
companionship you know we when i
arrived we were chatting about how this
environment that we're all living in
actually i
i love being on my own i i'm very happy
in my own company i'm very passionate
about what i do and i think that
fulfills the space that maybe other
people
have other that have other passions for
right and so
yeah it's never been a it's never been a
goal of mine i've never dreamt of the
white wedding i've never wanted to
and there's never a bit of me that sits
at home and thinks i wish i had someone
to sit and watch television ever
that doesn't doesn't even cross my mind
and my mates are always like do you not
get lonely or do you not worry and i'm
like
no i feel like i should because it would
make you all feel better
but and you know about five or six years
ago because everyone was on at me all
the time i'd like
did a bit of dating did some internet
you know use some apps everything else i
was like this why am i doing this i'm
doing this because society wants me to
do this i'm doing this because my mates
want me to do this this is [ __ ] uh
if it's right if it's right it'll come
if it's not it won't did you did you
date at all throughout the last
i guess decade did you here and there
but it's like
kill me you know kill me now you know
that kind of small
talk oh god it's like my idea of hell on
earth going and meeting a stranger
having small talk slightly awkward with
kind of one end game
do you know what i mean and it's like
and i'll know within two minutes of that
end game's happening and then i'm like i
don't really need this bulldog
for an hour and a half yeah we don't
need to dress this up so yeah no i just
yeah it just never yeah i did a little
bit but it's not it's
i'm not looking for that and i think if
i'm looking if i if i wanted if i wanted
to get married if i wanted to get into a
relationship
i could and i'm not i'm not adverse to
it but i'm just not out seeking it
and i i think you get what you look for
right yeah so other sacrifice um
i don't think it's a sacrifice by the
way yeah generally i need it no i i
do you know what the reason why when i
was younger i wouldn't have thought it
was a sacrifice and then i started
reading all this stuff about
the importance of like you know 18 19
and 20 even 24 year old steve would have
thought you know i don't need to [ __ ]
anybody and i can just
i'll be fine i'm a lone wolf yeah and
then i fully went for the whole recluse
thing
like wholeheartedly and i was broke so i
had no choice anyway
so i was broke and i was just not this
renegade that was determined to build
build businesses
and then i started reading some stuff
and it talked about the importance of
like meaningful connections and
relationships and i realized that i
didn't really have those and
if i was going to become wildly
successful then it would just be me
and my louis vuitton bag set up inside
of my house and i and then and then i
started to change my perspective and
thought steve you know what
you need to create a little bit more
openness or balance towards that stuff
so i
tried a little bit more but that doesn't
i see i see i have incredibly meaningful
relationships and incredible connections
i have
my friend i have like five or six
friends who are
my world i mean i'm incredibly close to
them they are
they're kids they're you know my god
children i feel very very connected i
don't feel
isolated in any way i don't feel like
i'm missing out or
sort of not having to and i actively
participate in the lives of my friends
kids and
in my friends lives and i think that
that's my connection that's my tribe you
know i mean
they and you know i would go to war for
them and it's it
i just don't think that that added bit
of a companion
for me right now you know i'm not saying
not forever
but i'm not sure that bit for me is
something that i need and i think that
it's that there's a difference there
because i do agree with you i think you
should absolutely have to have
connection
the human condition is to feel connected
to feel part of something to
to feel you know sort of the that you'll
have a purpose within your community and
i think
having your own community and having
your own tribe is crucial
i don't think that needs to be through
companionship with one other human being
there's a pressure that you talked about
the societal pressure you know and i've
got to be honest right i'm going to be
completely honest because i would be
really dishonest if i didn't
say this i have been guilty of
when i have a friend who is struggling
in that department
feeling like i need to help them
because again that's my own world if you
pressed upon them i'm thinking well in
order
but in order for me to be happy i would
need that so i need to make sure you
have that thing right
that pressure especially for women is
intense post
30 and it causes a ton of anxiety i see
it in my
direct messages from strangers um
not easy well it's interesting though so
when i'm 42 now and the pressure drops
away because i think you get to the
point where people
think it's rude to ask if you're going
to have kids because they're like can
you still have kids
okay right fine you get to that age
right but but certainly all through my
30s
when you're going to settle down do you
not want to have children and i and i
feel very very lucky
that i feel the way i do i've never
really had a biological clock that's
ticked
ever and i've never felt the need for
companionship
of one other person like i said my tribe
is very important to me but
and i think that's potentially
biological so i think i'm lucky
i don't because i do i have friends who
you know they would
they're desperate to meet someone
they're desperate to have children
they're desperate to
move on to that bit of their life and
i've just never felt like that so it
and i feel very lucky because of that
because i think if i'd have felt like
that my whole life would be very
different
does nurture play a role in that because
i know it did for me yeah my
my parents were toxic for each other
like watching my mom scream at my dad
for seven hours a day every my mom's
like this
african nigerian woman and that the this
decibel she's able to achieve is like
gold medal worthy she is unbelievable
at shouting right and she can do this
amazingly high energetic scream
for seven hours a day without flinching
and i watched that as a kid growing up
my dad sat there this passive english
man
who didn't say a word ever and this
african woman just
just torturing him with this loud sound
and me thinking like the lesson i
learned was relationships
are prison and for this is the lesson i
like for a man
you are trapped and it's torture so any
time when i was young
like 16 a girl would like me and i'd
chase her and i'd try and get her on the
playground whatever
minute she said she liked me deep
feeling inside of me of like escape
quick
so i would like come up with all these
reasons why girls that i just spent the
last year pursuing
why we were not right and we couldn't be
together and she needed to leave me
alone
and i i didn't notice that until i was
like 25 and then i started to work on
that part
okay but nurture does that play a role
do you think in your
views on relationships or men or
whatever or women or whatever i think it
probably plays a role in my view of
having kids
because my mum was adopted so my mum
literally
didn't know who her mom and dad was she
was kind of picked out of an orphanage
by my grandparents
um and never hadn't until she had david
and i
had never met anyone who looked like her
you know like we all you know connect to
our families because we've got families
similar features whatever
she'd never had that and so my mum loves
my brother and i with a kind of
wonderfully oppressive kind of dominate
and it's you know she she just loves us
with everything that she's got because
we're
we're for a whole host of reasons but
also i think because we're the only
physical
you know sort of biological connection
she's ever had and that love always used
to scare me a little bit
you know not from her but i used to
think like i've got dogs
and i worry about my dogs and i've got
like nine god children i've got two
nephews and a niece and
the minute they get on a plane or they
go i'm panicking like what if the plane
crashes what if they die what if it's
like
i can't handle it and i'm like jesus if
i'd have had my own kids
that would i wouldn't have been able to
handle the that amount of love
i know that sounds ridiculous but i
think that always played quite a big
part for me that i was like
the responsibility of it the constantly
having to worry about it
the constant all of my female friends
who have kids
they live in a state of almost permanent
anxiety because they worry about their
kids all the time
in a in a love way you know it's like
that wrong love you have for a puppy
um but and i don't think i ever i've
never felt that i wanted that in my life
i never thought that i needed it and i
never felt that i wanted it i always
felt quite like
no i'm good i've got the right amount of
love going on in my life
i don't want that additional
responsibility and burden in many ways
of having something that
is always ever present and and would
cause me i think quite a lot of anxiety
is that in part because you have so much
responsibility
and naturally honestly worry that comes
from your other love in life which is
your career yeah
for sure yeah because that's the way i
feel it's like a kid as well i really
have yeah
yeah and it's why i don't think i need a
companion
because i already have i get so
fulfilled from my job i get so
i get so much from that and so much from
kind of working in and around people and
having that kind of
i've got the community of my friends and
the community of my work and i think
those
those two things i find very fulfilling
so the idea of having
a companion or children or anything else
in the mix of that
didn't really ever appeal to me in
interest i mean i was i was engaged to
be married when my brother got
uh served his band say 2004. and i've
been with the guy for like
i don't know seven years and i remember
like
moving into our how we bought a house
together in shepherd's bush and we moved
into the house and i remember
like vividly putting the key in the door
turning the lock and thinking i don't
want this
like i don't want this i loved him to
bits he was an amazing guy but i was
like i don't want this kind of
i don't want to be in a normal life with
a normal husband and a
house and kids and i just didn't want it
i wanted something different
i've got a tattoo that says a lifeless
ordinary i just wanted to just do it
differently and i don't know where that
came from
but i've had it my whole life that kind
of i just don't
i just didn't feel the need to conform
to society's kind of
pillars overcame you go to university
and then you're going to get a job and
then you're going to meet a guy and then
you're going to get married
then you're going to have kids i was
always like not interested
any idea why no and i'm fascinated by it
because i feel very blessed because of
it
because it's like i say i think it's it
given me a freedom that a lot of people
don't have
had you wanted it had you wanted that
you know
you know the typical life that society
says people have to live and
followed all the timelines and
milestones do you think you would have
been able to achieve as much as you have
i was in my head my ego was going i
would have been amazing at it
i'd have been like a boss um no because
i don't think you can i don't i you know
i'm
i'm a feminist i'm a you know i'm
absolutely passionate about equality i'm
passionate about women's ability you
know women can do anything that men can
do and should have the opportunity to do
that
but i equally don't think it's possible
to have it all i really don't i don't
think you can have
and i know there are women who do and
perhaps off to them i think it's
incredible you read about these women in
the city who've got like
five kids and they're ceos and it's like
fair play to you but i couldn't do that
because i would feel constantly
compromising and i don't like compromise
and you're obsessive a little bit in
terms of your focus
i don't like compromising i yeah i
probably am obsessive makes it sound a
bit like it's
it's i'm not in control of it i'm in
control i'm aware of what i'm doing
but it's a bit like i so i'm we were
talking about having a peloton and you
know
i kind of feel if i'm going to go all in
on my fitness and my health and get
lean and everything from my 40th i got
like down to 65 kilos i was like a boss
and i was like all over it
but then i was a bit like crap i've got
to do my job as well and i sort of feel
like i'm i'm not great at doing
having two or three focuses i can i can
go at one thing
and be brilliant at it but if i start
adding in layers of
complexity like i can stay on top of my
health i can stay on top of my fitness
but i can't if once i start going down
there right i'm gonna get super lean i
find it hard to manage my work do you
know what i mean so
i don't know there's obsession or
whether it's just my opinion i'm myopic
sure yeah
if people were to you know people they
read about you online and they say
you've
been the ceo of this amazing sports team
you ran your own agency before that
you're now the ceo of bell's staff
a lot of people especially young women
are going to think that's exactly what i
want to do they're going to think that's
amazing
there's always a disclaimer that comes
with all of these things what is the
disclaimer
in terms of the cost of the success
you've achieved
what are the things that you know if i'm
you you would turn to me as a
as a young aspiring ambitious person and
say by the way before you follow in my
footsteps here's what you need to know
you know i wouldn't have fun because i
think yeah i really wouldn't
i i feel exceptionally blessed i feel
really
i love what i do i've loved the journey
i've been on like all the mistakes i've
made and
like i said at the beginning you know
i've been very very lucky to be allowed
to
make all kinds of mistakes and then not
follow me around it's like i've been
kind of
carried and supported and encouraged to
to fail
and to try and to do stuff that other
people just wouldn't have got the chance
to do
so i'd be like no go for it like don't
don't
worry about it like don't worry about
[ __ ] up don't worry about making
mistakes let's get on with it
what would you tell me though that i had
to have in terms of my qualities would
you say okay well if you're going to
follow my footsteps then you're going to
need a little bit of this and a little
bit of that
it's so hard isn't it stephen because
you can't follow in someone's footsteps
that's true
it's impossible and that's the thing i
think that people
you know i would say you can't you can
have your own footsteps and you can go
into your own thing and
jesus if someone says to me at 25 this
is the career path you're going to
follow i've been like
there's just no way there's no way i
could tell someone how they're going to
do that because it's
bonkers i explain to people some you
know people like oh you know tell me a
bit about your background and i
i hear myself saying it i'm like that's
bonkers
so i don't you can follow in someone
else's footsteps but i do think it's
like
a bit like the beginning i was like you
know just
be yourself you know be nice to people
be approachable
take the opportunities when they're
given to you recognize that sometimes
things are scary and you're going to
have to do it scared
and actually change is sometimes the
best thing that can happen to you and
you know all those things that you read
in cliche memes on instagram
they're pretty much true you know what i
mean it is it's and you've just got to
take that approach in life because
you're not going to get another one but
it's not easy fran it's the stress
of your job it must be pretty intense
you're running now
um a big company that's you know in the
process of like sort of turning
themselves around and kind of
reinventing themselves to some degree
and i know the stuff that you have to
deal with because i've dealt with it
yeah but i'm not curing cancer but it's
i feel like a lot of it's relative
right still big problems are big
problems for
relative to the challenge you're facing
so like that's i guess tell me about
that perspective though because a lot of
people would be like oh my god that's
a tough you know you're in a tough job
and there's problems everything i'm so
lucky steven that's the thing i think
you're like i'm so
someone you know an incredibly
successful
man bought a business three years ago
and has said to me it's not working very
well
i i really like what i've seen you do in
the two years i've been exposed to you
could you go and run it for me
it's like yes yeah i'll go and do that
what a great opportunity and i'm
and i'm just it's i just feel very lucky
and yeah they're big challenges and you
know brexit at the moment's bonkers and
all our shops are shut because i've
covered and i'm having to meet and work
with new people but
you know i wouldn't change it for the
world i think it's i think i'm
i think if you can and this is where
steve peters has been so powerful
because he's like it it's a bit about it
not defining you you just
just try your best dude and that was you
know what uh jim ratcliff actually text
me
i text and say thank you very much for
the opportunity we're not friends we
don't like hang out
thank you so much for the opportunity
this is incredible because i hadn't
spoken to him about it at all it was all
via sort of you know
determined in the business and he just
he just replied and said
fran the only thing i can ask you to do
is your best and you know when you're
like
the freedom of that the the op and
that's what dave b has always been like
he's like you can just do your best
friend you can't there's nothing more
you can do in life
and i think if you release yourself of
expectations and
what's the standard you've got this
don't get me wrong i did not feel like
this for the last 10
15 years this has been in the last
probably two years
that i started to realize you know what
what is the worst that's gonna happen
like what's the worst case scenario here
bellstar folds
let's say or when i was in the cycling
team we didn't win the biggest bite race
or
you know whatever as long as no one's
dying as long as nothing's
you know that as long as people are okay
the people are okay
i'm kind of i'm kind of all right with
it you know it's
just there's life and one of the things
i mean i completely i completely
understand i
tend to believe that anything caring
about anything beyond your best is like
anxiety and worry and useless
yeah it's like that mark twain quote
isn't it it's like there's a men they'll
spend their whole lives worrying about
stuff that's never actually going to
happen and isn't it that's what worry is
because you're worrying about something
it hasn't even happened yet or that sort
of
um there's a brilliant renee brown
podcast where she talks about foreboding
joy
and it's this idea that you something
really exciting is happening
but all you're thinking about is [ __ ]
what if it goes wrong so rather than
enjoying
the joy of it the kind of you know she
uses the example that she's on the plane
to go
to her first oprah appearance and she's
like i spent the entire plane journey
there worrying the plane was going to
crash
then i spent the whole car journey there
wearing that i was going to make a
mistake on the show or say something
stupid
then i spent the whole time in the green
room worrying i was wearing the wrong
outfit
and at no point did i stop and think i'm
going on oprah
this is amazing and it's that isn't it
it's like i think you can
burden yourself with all this
responsibility and all these kind of
negatives and actually it's like we just
want an opportunity why don't
you try and flip it try and see the
world in a bit more of a positive light
and i feel like that
that's something i'm really working on
for myself because i just think
like i say we only get one of them you
get this one opportunity i've been very
lucky
there's nothing in my life touchwood
that has caused
real trauma or you know that i feel that
i
would go back and change and i think
when you're halfway through that's not a
bad place to be
you took the job uh in the middle of the
midst of covered yeah it was
october the 1st first started october
the 1st that's brave
in retail i know i'm crazy that's well
yeah yeah brave
no but being positive being optimistic
about it you're coming into this
business and
it's um i mean it's been smashed in all
directions by all things
um what's your what's your what's your
what's your approach what's your
strategy what are you thinking
i mean at the moment well the first
three months in the business i just
wanted to get to know everyone there so
i did one to one to everyone
i think it's really easy to kind of go
into business with preconceptions of
what's gone wrong and what what you'd
fix and i tried i spoke to all the kind
of
mentors i've worked with over the years
and said like what would you and they
all gave me the same advice which was
speak to people listen don't make any
rash decisions you know
wait get up get a proper plan but give
it you know the kind of 100 days
piece and initially i was like
i don't need to do that and actually you
just really do you know so i've just
spent
just trying to understand how it went
and the other thing is understand the
industry you know like i
literally knew nothing about the other
than i buy clothes i didn't know
anything about fashion
so so yeah so and now my plan is i you
know
as is always my ambition i want to do
the best possible job of it
i believe in bell staff as a brand um i
think it's an incredible brand with an
incredible history
i think the product is amazing i think
the design team have been doing a
brilliant job over the last three years
getting the product to a place that's
really true to who we are as a company
um and i
and i would really love to take it to
profitability and beyond you know i
really i really believe that it's
possible to do that
and i think you know we're lucky to have
the backing of jim and ineos
to support us through what is going to
be quite a significant period of
transition and change
but then i think we build the
foundations for growth and go from there
and retail's changed a lot
yeah totally
you know thinking about the high street
and how you know in e-commerce and the
internet now like
there's anyways we saw debenhams being
bought by boohoo and it's also just
bought
topman and some of the other arcadia
brands it's a
moment of transition that's been
accelerated by this pandemic what's your
thinking about
the changes with in retail i mean god
i'm so early to it
you know but i mean i think like
anything it's just i think it's
accelerated what was happening anyway
right like the high streets were were
dying people were moving online
i think the rapidity of that change has
just been you know it accelerated
massively so
people's behavior around how they're
shopping was was on the
cusp of quite significant change i think
that change has flipped massively so
you know people are much much happier
shopping online even like an older
generation who historically wouldn't
have been
i do fundamentally believe when we all
start opening up again people are really
going to want to go shopping
you know and i think people are going to
this idea that people aren't going to go
to the shops i'm
not sure i buy it because i think it's
like yeah you want to get out
let's go and do stuff even you might
want to stephen
there's always hope isn't that you know
i see shopping is not actually for the
purpose of shopping i see it as an
experience
and i see the internet as a place where
if i almost the utility and shopping is
like a
thing to do right yeah so i do i do
wonder if retail will will
seize hold of that part and have the
experience experience
yeah exactly i think that it's going to
have to because i don't think it's ever
going to be there to be making money
so i think it's going to be about adding
on the experience of the brand for
people particularly for our brand you
know we
we can create an experience and a story
and a narrative that other brands maybe
can't you have a 96 years old
so yeah we've got all of that heritage
that i think we can speak to so i think
i definitely think that experiential
piece will be quite
a big play over the next few years this
is a morbid question
but i like to ask it sometimes i think
sometimes are you scared of dying
no no
are you no i was when i was religious up
until about 18 years old and then once i
realized that i was going to the same
place that i came from which was
nothingness and peace
it was quite a liberating feeling and i
thought death was actually
i would dare i say not a good thing but
um not something to be scared of
interestingly i had to uh when would it
have been so
three three years ago i crashed my bike
and landed on my head
and i got like i mean for some reason
whenever i crashed my back i landed
either my face or my head
and i landed on my head towards your
brains it's just
i wish and um our team doctor at the
time
was like because i'd got a bit of
concussion he was like i think you
should go and get a brain scan
he's very over cautious so i went and
got an mri and
mike they've made my mum come up because
i don't have her husband so after
that that's the one downside actually to
being single is that whenever you have
to have like somebody come and look
after you it's like mum
i'm 42 years old but please could you
come and stay at my house um so my mum
had to come up because of the concussion
i wasn't allowed to go home on my own
and i got this phone call from a brain
surgeon
who had been given my mr they looked at
my mri
and they'd found all these patches in my
brain and he was like there's these
we've found is are you
he rang me and he's like are you with
someone and i was like
yeah and he's like oh we've got yeah and
he's like we've got a [ __ ]
just tell me bedside manner he's
improving um
and he said um we've got your brain
scans we've gone through them and
they're
we're seeing changes in your brain and
you know when you're like but i've never
had an mri so how can you
how can you have how are there changes
anyway long story short
i've got all of these unusual patterns
in my brain like
patches that could be they were like
they could be potentially the starts of
tumors they could be
just your i know right they could until
you went through excuse me
rude i had to go and like so i went with
my best mate actually and go meet the
brain surgeon he talked us through it
and i mean she
it was one of those hilarious and
horrible situations all at the same time
because he was sort of going through
because she she works the nhs and she's
like what could what else could it be if
it's not team as well
could it be and he's like well you know
have you ever been like a very heavy
drug user and we're both like
no and she was like yeah she was like
this week lizzy we don't need to go into
this he means heroin
she's like oh yeah no no we've never
done heroin um and so
and she was asking all these questions
and so
basically i had about a year period
where they weren't sure what it was they
still aren't i still have them
and it's symptom-based so they're like
we could do biopsies and see what it is
and i'm like
nah you're all right um or or if i ever
develop symptoms which would be you know
sort of electric pulsing or anything
like that and i think that period is
quite good for me because it
and it's probably where a lot of the
positivity in there actually doing what
you only get one chance thing came from
because i
i was a bit like [ __ ] if i have tumors
kept growing in my brain
that's quite intense and what does that
mean for my life like
what would i change like what would i do
differently
and i genuinely i remember being sat in
my living room
having everyone had gone home by this
point and i sort of had had my first
proper
other ski it's like a two-hour mri which
is quite intense
and i was like you know i wouldn't
change anything i would carry on living
my life the way i live it now
i wouldn't change anything i would i
would probably
go deeper and harder in some of the
things that i really enjoy because i
like my job and seeing my mates i
would keep spending the money the way i
spend it i literally wouldn't change
anything and i was like and it felt it
literally felt quite freeing it was like
great this is this is good because i
think a lot of people would get that
kind of
diagnosis and be like right [ __ ] what do
i need to do differently and i didn't
have anything that i thought
no i wanted i don't want to change but
interestingly my
my job has now changed and i think deep
down the reason i had the chairman
conversation the reason i was willing to
say yes to this opportunity at bellstaff
is
had i maybe not had that incident and
had all of that
associated thinking and sort of bit of
deep deep sort of
soul-searching i maybe wouldn't i maybe
would have said no it's right i'll stay
at cycling
but i just thought you know what [ __ ] it
let's go and give it a try
what an absolute blessing that is to
know to know that you wouldn't change
anything i think
i am i have this sand timer
is it behind me somewhere is it there
it's usually sat behind me
but the reason i have a sand timer in my
house is because it's that sort of
visual it's the only way you can really
see time
at some point i realized that um i was
getting older and that
you don't notice and that you can fall
into the trap of thinking and
as i think most people do that will just
like live forever yeah and it's not
until you realize that life is finite
you have those
those moments that you realize that you
know like at some point i'm gonna die
and seeing my time pouring away is that
reminder of like is this
important and am i making the right
decisions am i living true to myself
um and i wrote a little article about
that called deathbed thinking which
pretty much says the same thing which is
that giving you that perspective of
from your deathbed potentially you know
what what really matters
remarkable um i mean i'm so i'm so
inspired by your story and every time i
sit down with someone
um who's become a success in their
career or their you know step issue i
i it feels like there's similar themes
but so so different in so many ways
what what does the future hold for you
do you think do you know
any ideas you're going to end up world
domination right no exactly
no i would believe you if you said that
that's the funny thing i took that
seriously i don't know what the future
holds
and i don't really mind like i don't
mind i sort of as long as
as long as my family and friends are
healthy and happy and as long as
you know actually that's all that
matters as long as my friends and family
are
happy and healthy and then i'm pretty
cool with whatever the world throws at
me i'm
i'm sure it will be a laugh it'll be fun
everyone else seems to need a plan
no that's that's five year plan three
year plan don't get me wrong i used to
have five year plans but they're all
hilarious when i go back and look at my
five year plans i'm like oh i love how
ambitious i was
like where's that yacht
i think when i was a kid i was very i
remember actually when i set my agency
up my best mate and i
set it up together and we got a coach
and we were about 22
23 and the coach was like right go off
into separate rooms and write out where
you want to be in 10 years time
and then come back in and read them to
each other and we were best mates like
we lived together for like three or four
years
set a business up together he was dating
my best friend we came back in and he
and we had them base right like written
on a piece of paper like holding from
each other
and he was like right i want to be
running a successful business earning a
good salary i want to be living in a
nice house with a wife and three
children
um and i want to be healthy and happy
and i was like
oh [ __ ] you've done it you're listening
i want a yacht
and a chair i want to have loads of
money yeah i was literally i had this
like really materialistic
list about wanting to be like successful
in a global
sensation and have all this money and
all this cold 23 22 23
did you have stuff growing up material
stuff yeah we were quite not i mean
when mike was my dad my dad was in the
raf so to begin with you know
middle class but then when he left to go
to hong kong he went into civil aviation
in kind of the glory
of the expats so definitely very very
lucky and i got you know
business class travel everywhere yeah so
it was
pretty next level yeah it's incredible
that you've wanted it for
you it's so bad but now i wouldn't i
wouldn't want that list now but it was
just
it was that really interesting like oh
okay we want totally different things
and i i didn't have partner i didn't
have kids i didn't have a nice house
anywhere i was like
i wanted the i wanted the universe you
know i mean i want to go over there and
do something massive
well you've smashed it fran and i'm sure
you've you've been paid well along the
way for that
um money the money becomes irrelevant
though right the money is not
the money is just a great tool for
helping my friends and family for doing
cool stuff with people so having
experiences
i spend all the money i earn doing stuff
with the people i love
give me an example uh took my
sister-in-law to dubai for her 40th
birthday with my best mate we stayed on
the palm with an amazing time i've
sort of took my brothers back to hong
kong for his 40th
i take my friends on holidays i yeah i
just
go and do stuff with the people i love
experiences i spend my money on
experiences going and doing stuff seeing
stuff but always with the people i love
and none of my mates can afford to go to
the hotels i go to so i was like well
i'll just pay
because i don't want to stay in a rugby
showtime so
i can relate well listen thank you so
much for all of your time today it's
been truly fascinating and even you know
researching your background and your
mindset has been
um really really inspiring and
energizing for me
and i can relate to so many elements and
the other other elements i'm just
amazed and impressed by so thank you for
your time i know you're incredibly busy
person so it feels like an
additional honor for you to have said
yes to come and chat to me today
um and where can people find you i guess
just you know these days it's pretty
easy you just google someone's name but
yeah i don't do i i have a private
instagram and i do i'm on twitter but i
don't really
use it very often so and i'm rubbish
with linkedin well if they want to speak
to enough i'm sure they'll
find me they'll find me yeah and thank
you so much for inviting me it's been
fascinating i've really enjoyed talking
to you
thank you thanks
people ask me for book recommendations
all the time and i finally got one for
you
it's a book called happy sexy
millionaire
which is authored by me i spent the last
almost two years in jungles around the
world in costa rica and indonesia
in solitude writing this book it's the
most important thing i've ever
created and there's this crazy thing
when you write a book because
you spend so much time pouring your
heart and soul into it and everything
you know and all of the revelations
you've had in your life
and then there's this barrier which is
that people have to buy the thing in
order for them to get
that thing that means so much to you i
wish that wasn't the case
it's just the way the industry is and in
order to get that distribution and to
get it on shelves you need a publisher
so
please please please if you can if
you've ever liked anything i've
ever produced this podcast my instagrams
anything i've ever said
read this book there was no ghostwriter
i wrote every single word myself there's
some real surprises in there it's an
honest sometimes hilarious incredibly
vulnerable
hopefully valuable recount of my life my
journey
everything i've learned across across
the way and really the answer to being
fulfilled to being happy and to
achieving success
it is the most important important thing
i've ever created so i implore you to go
to amazon now or wherever you get your
books
and get that pre-order and everybody
that pre-orders the book because
pre-orders
in this crazy publishing industry count
as way more than just a normal sale
if you get that pre-order i'm going to
put you into a group with everybody
that's pre-ordered it
and i'm going to send you some exclusive
stuff so the first things i'm going to
do is a series of voice notes which i
think are
um are going to be pretty powerful i'm
going to give you access to some tickets
which nobody else will have
and i'm going to do everything i can to
thank you for for giving me that sort of
nine quid of your money whatever it is
happy sexy millionaire you can pre-order
it everywhere now and if you do get that
pre-order please do dm me because i'd
love to thank you myself
[Music]
[Music]
you